I'll walk him to this video playing mr.
Boris mr. Boris from the UK see got a
title no I'm pretty good rating so let's
see ya i dont je one-tenth open Sicilian
you at the moment just play the check
the Moscow variation this is a new idea
should be should be three and recently
got popular the idea is to put the
bishop here on c2 and go for a structure
that is quite comparable to this to the
Royal Lopes leading to very interesting
strategical battles ok interesting
flavor black here I still won't know
what about Bishop f4 is this possibility
attacking attacking his soft spot
immediately yeah he might take d 4 but
come on on this Bishop on the six is not
there not bad ok the other move that I'm
wondering about is Bishop g5 why is the
Queen going or each five actually I'm
already only one with the rook if I if I
might just cancel ok I'm John let's just
play this and hope that it is working
out fine didn't really calculate it too
much
yeah maybe black yeah well he decided to
to to take up the challenge yeah of
course this is a sacrifice but I wonder
I want to try to exploit this the bishop
he on d6 ok if it takes f3 Queen takes
the normal reply but he might have 95
just 95 yeah but taking with the party
looks entirely ridiculous check take
here 95 yeah 295 I don't really have a
move to keeper yeah maybe quickie one
may even even night see for that isn't
but i have e five then why'd it gets
tricky ok very tricky yeah of course
that's also possible very young greedy
move not sure how good it is but he
played the draw the brother instantly as
usual and ok so I wonder 93 94 e 5 they
love all pretty dangerous let's consider
you five intending eat six yeah all this
that's already e6 is already a pretty
big threat
so if he takes it what am I going to
play esox is not f6 but I happy should
be three as well that's maybe even
better intending Queen f7 check made and
how to see how does he actually prevent
it 95 Queen f7 estilo mate and rook f-86
gets very very very very tricky and I
can take f8 on top of all of that yeah
which is even better you should've ate
there's still no way to defend f7 yeah I
don't see a defense really maybe you'd
still look a fade taking it and don't
know I don't know really was there is
their defense can you move the F porn
maybe f5 take with the porn on pasong
and f7 Jack made coming
Jeff no defense
yeah I don't know I thought I think you
really took all this really quickly
especially Bishop b2 I mean 95 or so i
think i'm just a better defense okay so
this is not the direct made it seems but
i can i can take f7 and play e6 just a
moment okay but yes it's enough it is
enough i think with e 7 coming that's
it's too much wrong it does not have you
just not have a check or anything b7
with the mate when I don't see anything
against that
well that's it yak resign this is really
see this possibility queenetta it's just
it just too much it was really surprised
how quickly took all that here here
95-year the computer confirms that 95 is
better at least 95 it says minus 0.6
which is possible i mean i'm not sure
that all this was was too brilliant but
it was interesting I'm 95 year I thought
queen d 194 and e5 this was my idea but
the computer is just checking that and
play Bush should be six male with a good
position yeah two bishops on an open
bought and he will castle on like smooth
like that which is just excellent for
black yeah I don't know this means that
maybe I must take maybe I must take and
hope for my my development so I'm with
95 and so on but it's still two bishops
yeah but he took here and after you five
white already Wednesday of the computer
is on plus five yeah it took it really
quickly two seconds yeah I mean he
probably had decided beforehand to take
but still it's very critical and e5 I
don't know it's I think it's very
obvious that it is super dangerous I
wasn't sure that I'm winning the
computer now confirms that i actually do
but run it looked very very dangerous to
me what what what should you do and
there is no movie sixes threat do should
be oops bishop to be three as the threat
you have only played that and Bishop b3
is killing I don't think that II six is
six wins as well okay I thought that
this might might help okay this is
Janice is actually quite cute a bishop
a4 b5 Quincy six and i'm going to take
on this happen with a double check mate
almost almost ok so this this means this
was even easier because well if you
cannot play Knight f6 what should you do
completely busted ok but this wins as
well you six again is winning but this
is also also check also killing black
mat here you cannot cannot avoid
disaster with the with a me to come
alright this wasn't to correct me but
interesting thanks for watching